new details emerge about Corinne olimpio
psa's short-lived time in Paradise
bachelor in paradise resumed production
on season four last month after
concluding that no misconduct occurred
between elympios and another contestant
Demario Jackson now acerous claims to et
that the reality star was never
unconscious during filming but alleges
that she did blackout from drinking
alcohol and taking prescription
medication quote Corinne's condition was
exacerbated by the drinking and taking
the prescribed medication olimpio says
rep had no comment regarding the
allegation last week elympios announced
that she will appear on the upcoming
reunion show for bachelor in paradise
Jackson previously confirmed that he
will be in attendance as well Olympia's
told ET in a statement last month that
her team's investigation into what
happened on set had been completed to
her satisfaction quote I felt it was
very important to be thorough in getting
to the bottom of what had occurred I
myself had no recollection of the events
that transpired
[Music]